remembering september 11th 20 years
later it's a day that changed our city
and our nation forever today families
read the names of lost loved ones at the
world trade center site in new york city
a year after having to do it virtually
because of the pandemic craig treadway
has a look at today's ceremony that
honored the thousands who perished there
it was the deadliest attack on american
soil and it cut america deep to the core
and today the pain is still there
today's official service began at 8 40
with a bagpipe processional followed by
the national anthem
family members then began reading the
names of all those who died as a result
of the 2001 attacks and the 1993 bombing
andrew anthony abate a moment of silence
at 8 46
marking the time the first plane struck
the north tower
three presidents came to honor the
fallen this 20th year bruce springsteen
paid his respects with a song
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
families remembered their loved ones
carl can't believe it's been 20 years
your children amanda and michael are
living your legacy
they are walking in your footsteps and
making a difference in this world
we love you so much
thank you for watching over us we miss
you
and please convince mommy to get us a
husky someday and as the names were
being read flowers were placed around
the memorial pool kelly o'hara giving a
powerful performance of you'll never
walk alone
along with hamilton's christopher
jackson
[Music]
two decades later the pain still deep
for so many
and the memories just as deep
as it has for the past 20 years the
ceremony ended with the playing of taps
president joe biden left the ceremony at
10 45 to head to shanksville
pennsylvania where flight 93 crashed he
will end his day at the pentagon
in jersey city new jersey i'm correct
treadway